Want to get rid of the president? Awesome.
First, find an impeachable offense:
What's an impeachable offense?
Treason, Bribery or "Other High Crimes and
Misdemeanors."
Okay, so what's "other high crimes and misdemeanors?"
Nobody knows.
Some people say it means bad things only people
in high office can do -
like misusing public assets or dereliction
of duty
or getting a hummer under the Resolute Desk.
Others say it doesn’t mean minor, everyday
criminal behavior —
just really bad criminal behavior,
like lying under oath about getting a hummer
under the Resolute desk.
Others say it's any crime or misdemeanor at all,
even if it has nothing to do with their their position of power.
Did you steal that pen from work?
Petty theft is a misdemeanor.
You are no longer President.
Government officials have been impeached for
submitting false expense reports,
lying under oath, even showing up to work drunk.
It's a pretty wide net.
Of course, this is the highest office in the
land we're talking about,
and considering all the shit presidents have
done without being impeached,
it's a pretty high bar.
So to sum up: it's a wide net, with a high
bar.
So once you get an impeachable offense,
get a majority of the house to vote for it
and then go to trial in the Senate --
call witnesses, present evidence --
it's pretty much like a normal court case,
except the judge is the chief justice of the supreme court,
the prosecuting attorneys are members of the
House,
and it takes place in the freaking Senate.
Then after a couple of months of the highest
rated programming in CSPAN history,
the senators vote -- and if 67 senators find
the President guilty, he's gone.
But what if there was another way?
Without all that messy law and order stuff?
The Vice President and a majority of the cabinet
can invoke the 25th amendment
and present a written declaration to Congress
that the President is "unable to discharge
the powers and duties of his office,"
Okay, what does that mean?
Well, in the past it's been used for things
like "Hey, I'm getting a colonoscopy,
can you cover for me for a few hours?"
but now some people want it to mean "I just
think this guy is an asshat."
Regardless of the rationale, once those articles
are invoked, the magic wand is waved
and the President is immediately stripped
of power.
No trial, no witnesses, no evidence, no votes
-- just gone.
Of course the President is going to say "Hey,
I'm totally fit for office,
get out of my chair"
but if the Vice President won't budge, then
it goes back to congress,
which will have three weeks to decide who
gets to run things.
This time though you need 2/3rds of the Senate
and 2/3rds of the House
or maybe it's 2/3rds of the Senate and the
House,
nobody really knows because it's never happened
before
and it'll probably end up going to the Supreme
Court anyway.
Regardless, if enough of them agree that the
President is an asshat or whatever,
the Vice President stays put,
and the President is never heard from again.
Or more likely he goes on twitter
and says this was an extra-judicial coup by Washington insiders
and starts a new civil war, only this time
with bigger guns
and planes and bombs and stuff.
So maybe we shouldn't decide to get rid of
a President just because we hate them
and then, afterwards, figure out how to pretend
it's the law.